bonsoir
quel est mon pain merci d'être avec nous
donc ce revers infligé à donald trump
par la cour suprême la lutte du
président pour invalider les résultats
de la présidentielle
est ce qu'elle est encore possible
désormais pas vraiment il semble
maintenant que donald trump va bien
devoir quitter la maison blanche et que
joe biden on va devenir président en
janvier
mais donald trump ne mettra jamais la
défaite c'est très important pour donald
trump il utilise le mot gagner beaucoup
il ajouté c'est lui qui fait gagner les
états unis qu'ils gagnent toujours
qu'elle ne perd jamais ce serait
vraiment un coup très fort contre la
base électorale de donald trump s'il
reconnaissait avoir perdu donc il va
continuer à prétendre qu'il a gagné mais
le processus normal américain va
continuer considérant qu'il a perdu
alors la strate donald trump en tout cas
pense désormais certainement au coude
après on a déjà commenté ici ou là est
ce qu'on sait déjà ce qu'il a dans la
tête
au moins pour les prochains mois se
lancent des actions symboliques et c'est
une sorte de miroir étrange à ce que
faisait part à cobham en avant de
quitter la maison blanche plusieurs
exécutions vont avoir lieu avant que
donald trump quitte le pouvoir
d'exécution niveau fédéral les
exécutions qui doivent être approuvées
par le président des états unis donald
trump semble vouloir donc faire exécuter
certaines personnes au niveau fédéral en
atteinte de leur peine de mort afin d'en
voir
message clair à ses soutiens par exemple
au sein des forces de l'ordre
expliquant qu'il continue à soutenir
l'appel de mort qu'il veut être sévère
envers les criminels et je pense qu'il y
aura d'autres actions ont fortement
symbolique je pense qu'il va mener des
actions à positive envers israël au
cours des mois à venir
je pense qu'il va essayer d'utiliser ces
- à venir pour assurer l'établissement
américain
ces partis de l'établissement qui l'ont
soutenu afin de leur dire que oui il est
bien de leur côté qui va essayer de
faire progresser le pays dans la
direction qu'il souhaite
brack obama avait utilisé ces derniers
mois afin d'imposer de nouvelles
sanctions contre la russie pour
condamner israël à l'onu il y aurait eu
également de discours très important
c'est noir ces derniers mois sont
vraiment le moment où les présidents
peuvent montrer peuvent donner les
derniers le ton de leur présidence alors
en tout cas un sujet semble être encore
sur toutes les lèvres bien évidemment
logiquement on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est la crise du corps d'un virus est
particulièrement la vaccination la
stratégie dans ce domaine semble un
enjeu capital autant encore pour donald
trump que pour joe biden pour quelle
raison la question du vaccin est une
source de confusion sur l'ensemble de
l'échiquier politique les démocrates ont
condamné les actions conservatrice qui
visait à répandre des théories du
complot anti vaccins mais n'oublions pas
qu'il ya également beaucoup de
scepticisme au sein du parti libéral ne
sont pas confiance à denain train peint
ce qu'ils accélèrent le processus d
essai pour des raisons politiques qui
donc il ya aussi de la méfiance de ce
côté là
il est attendu que beaucoup de doutes et
beaucoup de personnes se posent des
questions sur les actions des
entreprises pharmaceutiques
kamala harris lors du débat des lices
président avait dit qu'elle ne faisait
pas confiance au vaccin que proposerait
donald trump
donc il y a plus de flou sur tout
l'échiquier politique
alors il ya aussi un flou c'est sur la
quantité de vaccins et le manque de
vaccin semble être une vraie crainte
aussi bien pour donald trump que que joe
biden l'america firth a du plomb dans l
aile sur ce dossier c'est très
révélateur cela montre les faiblesses de
donald trump et du gouvernement
américain en général
16h20 des vaccins à d'autres
gouvernements
et nous n'a peut-être pas assez pour
fournir les états unis cela montre une
faiblesse majeure écoutant le
gouvernement des états unis depuis les
années 1980 on entendit aux états unis
que le gouvernement doit prendre du
recul qu'un bon gouvernement est un
gouvernement qui a un gouvernent peu et
nous nous retrouvons dans une situation
une entreprise américaine a découvert un
vaccin et le gouvernement américain
n'est pas assez puissant pour forcer
pour obliger cette entreprise a favorisé
à privilégier les américains donc c'est
une faiblesse structurelle le
gouvernement ne peut pas contrôler
l'économie ne peut pas forcer les
entreprises à respecter sa
hiérarchisation donc les producteurs de
vaccins privilégier d'autres pays c'est
la conclusion c'est de beaucoup et
beaucoup de nombreuses décennies de
réglementation ou les individus prennent
avantage sur les pays les gens à droite
c'est les nationalistes sont en colère
les gens à gauche et sociales y sont
également en colère le pouvoir des
entreprises
et des grandes multinationales et bien
plus grand bien trop grand pour que les
politiciens puis leur tenir tête et des
américains n'auront sans doute pas accès
aux vaccins dont ils ont besoin une
toute dernière question à thème que je
voulais aborder avec vous un joe biden
qui veut nommer l'ancien général lloyd
austin à la tête du pentagone c'est
l'une des dernières nouvelles comment
est accueillie cette information chez
vous barack obama kamala harris
il ya un désir de changer l'image des
états unis ils ne veulent plus que les
etats unis soient vus comme un pays
raciste un pays de colonisateurs montré
que le pentagone les états unis
répondent les droits de l'homme les
valeurs humanitaires dans le monde donc
avoir un afro-américain à la tête du
pentagone permettrait de faire avancer
cette image la droite les conservateurs
ont une vision différente de la
situation pour eux il s'agit d'être
puissant de terrifier le reste du monde
de renforcer la force militaire donc il
y a deux approches différentes
les démocrates seule dénomination
symbolique veulent essayer de changer
l'image la réputation des etats unis
veulent justifier l'interventionnisme
américain en se fondant sur des valeurs
libérales et les partisans de donna
tampon une autre approche
joe biden veut faire à des états unis un
pays antiracistes qui a dépassé les lois
jim crow un pays progressiste libéral
si libéral qu'un afro américain est à la
tête du dollar mais ce qui lui permettra
ensuite d'attaquer d'autres pays en les
accusant de ne pas être aussi ouvert
tolérant et libéraux que les états unis
donc c'est un changement de stratégie
merci beaucoup kalaba maupin
correspondant d'ayrté aux états unis
pour vu de l'extérieur merci à vous